Apparently, the train broke down
over theGuadalupe Bridge.
Service crew found it like this.
Lots of blood, no bodies…
and a pile
of missing persons reports.
Excuse me.
Greetings, young Trese.
Good evening, Nuno.
There was a time
when magic in the world
was a natural part of life.
That age has passed.
People fear
what they don't understand.
That's why our family
has always been thebridge
between mankind
and the supernatural.
What the hell are we dealing with?
A lot of tribes are on edge,
making bad deals with badder folk.
That balance you and your father
have tried so desperately
to maintain is at its end.
You're treading
on very thin ice, young Trese.
Can't be too sure
about the underworldthese days.
Please, help me.
You are the babaylan-mandirigma.
Healer and warrior.
Reveal what is concealed.
You were born ready.
Hank, the creature is a Tiyanak.
Do you hear it calling for me?
You want my advice?
Keep your heads down.
They're coming for revenge.
If the Lakan gets
in the way, kill her.
There's something bigger
going on here.
The tribes need to be united.
The tempest is brewing
and there are liars
amongst your allies.
Come on, boys.
Let's put an end to this.